hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play hide and seek
now this is another game to come out of
the seven-day first-person shooter game
jam which a lot of really interesting
creative games come out of these game
jams if you haven't seen them before you
should give them a try they're what
surgeon simulator came out of a game jam
I believe and many other games that you
might know but this is one of the horror
ones that I saw so let's give it a try
squeak I know hi there are you a monster
they earned it I told them to stop now
it's too late there's one last person I
have to kill so am i playing a monster
here oh no why not huh I'm running away
from a monster press shift to run wqa SD
to move what is queue do right-click to
talk now you should run away from the
door all right
okie dokie why o that Wow it's an
Indiana Jones thing we got a giant rock
coming at me barreling down the hallway
okay what do we what is that well that's
that thing from the screenshot I saw
what are you supposed to be hello who's
that Oh what is that it's like some
rolling blob of goop okay it's slowing
down alright whatever
hi oh hi kind of follow me around the
room you're weird
let's see what you gotta say this is
really well done I'm surprised don't let
him see you hide if you hear him coming
blink if you lose sanity and why should
I listen to you demon coming out of the
wall collect items with cherished
memories bring them back to me and why I
will kill him for you what if I don't
want that well I don't know what I want
you're so confusing left click to blink
the hallucinations away control the
clouds right-click to hide open or take
okay hi-yah rock on man Bobby okay
anyway okay so run it away from this guy
okay this game is really impressive I
gotta say it's really cool let's save
God what does that sound is that the guy
what does that a bone what does that
have a cherished memory we use this
bunker study huh what is that Bob why is
that link
what the hell was that oh the friggin
thing I've ever seen about live like a
face yeah it was like a face yeah great
commentary there market buyers nope
again are you okay alright alright this
is weird
who's this the flyer of my favorite
video game
goody hello were you a picture of my
last year's newborn what last year's
newborn little brother what your little
born brother what okay I probably
shouldn't go out into the hallway that's
where he is as I recall hello what is
that what is this door open these doors
should be closed too saying there's a
guy trying to kill me okay is there
another cherished memory here I see
something
give it give it guy I wanted to go oh
let me go hi hi
I died what happened what the hell
happened ah what the hell happened those
so weird and cool and I don't know where
am I I'm still alive
am I in purgatory this is how I respawn
this game is so cool this game is so
cool I've got like a permanent smile on
my face oh no I have to start all the
way back at the beginning well I saw I
saw like his arm in the doorway outside
I turned around and he got me I guess I
need a hide better not run
I'm gonna kill you with my giant claw
and my giant gob of goo purple goo okay
can I go in these doors now probably not
probably not a good idea let's go meet
up with the chief demonic creature which
is going to give me some advice on how
to survive this cuz that's totally
normal oh boy
hi mr. horn man are you doing give me
some advice don't let him see you yeah
you'll kill him okay I certainly believe
you left lick the blink to loosen ation
okay I'm not going in the left cuz that
one that first hallucination if that's
what it was was awful I want to see that
again
hide oh good a hiding place no don't
hide right now there's no need to hide
this I don't think there's a need to
hide is there any died okay I don't
think there was a need to hide okay what
is that what is that what is that that
is a creepiest doll I've ever seen in my
life for you the doll I've had since my
birth my great birth into this world
from the demonic realm of horrible
horrible this okay so he could be
popping out of the roof wow this is not
normal chair should not be on the
ceiling there's some cherished memory in
here huh
I hear something
I hear something I'm gonna leave the
door open discover I need to run into
the thing there wasn't a cherished
memory in it maybe hang on no no no
there we go oK we've got a picture of a
journey long ago isomerism here's a ball
oh I used to play football with my oh my
No thank you blink blink blink blink
lick lick lick lick lick lick why is
that
it's so weird oh those are so weird
this game is strange this game is pain
hello
I drew my drempt future house I don't
even care of your English is bad in this
game this game is horrifying this game
is awesome this is so original to kind
of itch a little bit keep searching for
what this is I've gotta buy dinner
is it Robin he's nearby is he I'm ready
please hop in the moment's notice
looky good bad Dobby on it screw it I'm
goin in I don't care what any of you
have to say I'm going in here and I'm
gonna tear there until the end of the
game
okay I guess there's nothing I think
he's close
I think he's nearby I just got to go out
here and do them into the dark and it's
all good
that's fantastic ah that's are done do
not knock on the car go getta getta
getta getta getta getta getta getta
getta getta good
wah I die I die oh yeah no guarding I
don't think I hit soon enough
I think going into that room where he's
hanging cuz I was him you can't tell me
that wasn't him hanging there
I was definitely him hi buddy are you
doing are you my little brother or some
man this game is amazing okay but um I
think I really like this kid sir
I'm getting a little overexcited you are
freaky you are Ricky yeah now you should
run away from the door
good advice I can't jump either so hmm
so I'm guessing that a guy just patrols
up and down the house the hallway yeah
buddy I was going okay
whatever you are I still don't know what
you are and why I need to deliver
cherished memories to you in order to
make everything all hunky-dory but
that's what I'm gonna do okay what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna go down here
I'm gonna get this one real quick these
in here Oh illusion nation oh god that
is a freaky face look out forget outside
eyes look away
Oh freaky face okay anyway so get this
you're not blink don't blink get that
get that okay and then there's I can
grab the oh no don't blink wow that was
weird
my my eyelids are must be really know by
high
blink nope I am dead okay hahaha
this game I swear all right this gives
us in one more try we're gonna give this
one more try
you barely going down the left side is
bad idea and then you're gonna need to
go there on the right side then loop up
the right side then go down the last
side cuz there's that one door that's
open that you don't want open you don't
want to leave that door open there
how about it how you dude you doing good
you do good you look good you look good
there you look real good all right let's
run this is like I got a steak this is
really cool I like the art style of the
game it's very cool there's a lot of
really interesting stuff going on
whatever the hell this is is really
well-made I mean it's just really cool
to come out of a seven-day Game Jam this
is amazing and horrifying and amazing
okay what I'm going to do is I'm going
to really quickly go in here get this
again
in that and then the hallucinations
gonna pop up out of the ground oh yeah
that horrifying oh oh yeah that's
actually pretty scary ah God okay
it wasn't gone I was very confused okay
so I need to get these two and then not
go in the next room and then I'll go
over to the other side if he's not right
there though okay good
coast is clear kind of a little bit
close that up get the weird freaky doll
dolls at iPod since my birth keep going
here get whatever was in here was over
here was over here picture all right
really good he's gonna lose that
okey dokey he Rob's of things
take him to bring me seven more oh my go
seven more I see him down there he's at
the end of that hallway okay that means
he's not in here right right that's how
that works right
okay oh hey
aha there are open doors they need to
close these doors up all right get the
thing in here the ball got that used to
play football
oh you hello you
freaky [ __ ] get out of here hi hi that's
hardly fair okay
this game is hard but really fun and
cool and awesome and you gotta try it oh
my god this is really amazing amazingly
well done love love this sound
atmosphere and the like dread I don't
know how he gets from point A to point B
but I just heard that door open and I
knew he was game over man game over I
don't know how the hiding mechanics seem
like they need a little bit of work
because I don't know how to get away
from him this is really hard so if you
guys can beat it let me know so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
Hey
boy
well
blood
huh
where's my